if women timed the fight for equality
brilliantly
right i mean brilliant 5 000 years
man we were fighting lions and tigers
and hunting buffalo
and when we were like we'll just pick
the berries you guys got that that's
you guys all right you guys are brave
look at
wow so courageous look at you hunting
that buffalo
second they put air conditioning in
office buildings women are like we
want equality
marks for it girls
it is hard for uh for women in a lot of
fields my friend's a pilot she said it's
very hard for women pilots because a lot
of discrimination against women pilots a
lot of bias
yes women pilots that's true i was on a
plane once the pilot came on it was a
woman it was a woman's voice she's like
this is your captain captain johnson
and everybody on the plane men and women
we're like what the [ __ ]
seriously put the real pilot on
this is a big fancy machine you're
driving buttercup all right
this ain't some kind of barbie's dream
car you're [ __ ] around with up there
women can do anything men can do except
math
chess running jumping lifting stuff
fixing things making money hockey
surfing
driving making decisions being tall
taking out the garbage
tipping fishing being funny on purpose
reading a map
listening to good bands writing running
the country
inventing anything important
or being fun to hang out with don't get
me wrong i love
women i just think they should drink
from a separate water fountain
okay actually women may be even better
than men
but we'll never really know since
they're swinging at bigger balls
playing from closer t's doing push-ups
from their knees
taking half the beatles money [ __ ]
please
the wnba officials expanded to 10 teams
this week adding franchises in detroit
and washington d.c but before you get
too excited
about the new additions to the league
remember all of the players are still
women
they stink at basketball that's the
problem
but i got to ask louis ck yeah like when
you
married your wife you were already in
comedy right yes i was so it's not like
you were
i didn't spring it on her no it wasn't
like you're working for nassau
you had a nine-to-five job you were
coming home and she knew what she was
getting into that you'd be there to
raise a kid
you when you guys met she knew you were
a road cop yes yes
but the way it's not even that i go on
the road the point is that i enjoy
my job right so she thinks of it that
because it's not like i'm going out and
slack she wishes i was doing a miserable
job and then she would be proud of me
come home yeah in order to put a roof
over the head but the fact that i do
something that i'm proud of that i love
doing
and but it still puts a roof over the
head but because women's
liberation that because there are women
that have
careers we're not allowed to say that we
are
providers anymore if you're a man but
the fact is my wife
lives off of my [ __ ] work and doesn't
do [ __ ]
so if she had a career then she could go
yeah [ __ ] you when you're open anthony
tour i don't care i'm i'm working too
yeah i got mine but the fact is she just
eats food that i
buy for her but i'm not allowed to point
that out or else i'm a male chauvinist
like i'm being a like backwards pig by
pointing out of the fact
which is that if i stop doing these fun
tours where i might get blown by a [ __ ]
or two
that she can't eat that she can't eat
anything because if she
tried to start making a l she's
worthless she has no
sense of she couldn't she could never
support our house
she could know it if we switched places
it would like some dumb sitcom
right uh the kids would be very happy
with me because i'm good at taking care
of the kids and be the fun guy hanging
around and my wife would be
unable to [ __ ] yeah hold down the job
she's never done it
really by the way you guys
like men in general you are filthy
yep you guys are gross
yeah yeah absolutely yeah
do you like it though
i don't know maybe in your religion lady
i
uh see men you cannot trust them
do you hear that men are going to be
obsolete in a few years
yeah yeah we're making synthetic sperm
so we don't even need you anymore
you might know but there's a couple up
there
i think you're going to fight you on
this plus
you know yes synthetic sperm yes
neatness
yes an orderly like what else what other
let's debate this what else you got me
for and make a case for men we're
awesome
hey
[Music]
let's get into this [ __ ] storm last week
i did a uh somebody asked me a question
about why when a guy does something um
for his girlfriend why is it never
enough
and one of the one of the problems that
uh i've had and that this guy had last
week is you you try to plan
something that both you and your
girlfriend can enjoy
as your night out and evidently women
have a problem
when you pick something for the both of
you to do
that you as a guy will also enjoy
evidently from what i'm reading from
these [ __ ] psycho emails that i got
this week
is that if it's not 100 about
them if you don't literally make a rose
bowl
[ __ ] float
sit them on it and then drag it down the
street with your [ __ ] teeth
they feel that you got too much
enjoyment out of the evening so
basically the evening
was it was really your evening it was
real look at the [ __ ] wedding day
you stand in it like an idiot and she
makes this grand entrance she gets some
one of a kind dress
and you you get a tuxedo that some
[ __ ] drunk's gonna wear
at a 15-year anniversary for a bowling
alley the next [ __ ] week
you know what i mean all right let's
listen to what the [ __ ] had to say
this week um all right hit this is this
this wonderful girl
and i say she's wonderful because she
actually admitted that she was a psycho
because i actually emailed her and asked
her why do you only respond
to male female [ __ ] and she sort of in
her own little cute way
admitted that she was a psycho so i
can't hate her but anyways this is her
email
hey bill i love the clueless email
questions from your male listeners
that's always a great way by the way to
get the other people to listen to what
you have to say
right out of the gate just start
insulting them and talking down to them
um he said the uh the guy was asking why
is it never enough to please a woman
since he admit he um and then she's
referring to his email
she says since he admits he isn't home a
lot
i'm guessing his wife slash girlfriend
is doing all the dirty work for him
his laundry cleaning cooking picking up
after him etc
all right let's stop right there
she's doing all the dirty work let me
ask you guys a question would you rather
sit home
doing laundry first of all laundry is
the most overrated [ __ ] chore
ever if you have laundry in your [ __ ]
apartment
what that takes all of a minute to load
the [ __ ] thing in and if you're not
color blind it probably takes 45 seconds
to
load it in and then you go back to
watching the prices right
cleaning cooking picking up after him i
would rather do that
than do what this other guy's doing this
other guy is working like 60 hours a
[ __ ] week
okay let's let's move it she's already
made this assumption okay then she
then she wants him to spend some some
time with him
and he comes up with something that he
wanted to do
just like when you took your girlfriend
on that drive all we heard about
was the love story between you and the
car you were more excited about the car
than anything
it was like you were on a date with the
car and your girlfriend just came along
for the ride
listen back to even the tone in your
voice when you were talking about it
it's like you were talking about another
woman
all right you know something i could sit
around for 20 years
trying to come up with the perfect
paragraph to talk how insanely
jealous and psychotic women are can you
they are they're jealous about an
inanimate object
she's talking about a car it's almost
like you were talking about another
woman
lady you are out of your [ __ ] mind
you're out of your [ __ ] mind and
you're totally
ignoring the fact that i took her out to
dinner i took her out to lunch
i took her up for a ride up to pacific
coast highway people
fly out here as a vacation to do that a
lot of couples do that and i'll tell you
right now they don't do it in a corvette
convertible
they do it in like a [ __ ]
whatever a buick century
really i mean it literally is never
enough
you're actually proving this guy point
this guy's point so she says my husband
does the same damn thing i'm like
what can we do for fun today tonight and
the only thing he can come up with
are things that interest him well what
can you come up with can you come up
with anything that doesn't interest
yourself you're selfish [ __ ]
you're doing the exact same [ __ ]
thing and it's unbelievably selfish for
you
to sit here and and and have like a
a a day that's for both of you and it
has to be 100
about you because what you did some
laundry you're lazy [ __ ]
your base you know what women are
they're basically they're like adult
children
that's what they are they never get
beyond
they're like juveniles they're adults
but they still want to be treated like
they're not of age
it's it's just [ __ ] boggles my
goddamn mind
um she goes i'd rather not do anything
at all
i think it's selfish and ignor and
obnoxious that everything we do
has to have his interest before mine
so everything that they do should have
your interests before his
you're yeah these [ __ ] broads they're
out see this is this is my thing this is
why
you should you should never get married
you should never be in a [ __ ]
relationship you shouldn't
because they just constantly [ __ ]
hack away at your goddamn knees and
their idea of a relationship
is that you do everything that they want
to do
and right now they're sitting there
shaking their heads they're going no
no even the girl wrote that's probably
saying no and there's a bunch of other
women going like
i'm not like that i'm not like that i
went to a ping pong convention they
always come up with some stupid ass
[ __ ] example and at the end of the
[ __ ] day
you have to do everything that they do
you have to do what the [ __ ] they want
to do
or else they get mad okay and that my
friend is when
jerking off comes into play
because when you really break it down
what's the worst thing that they're
gonna do to you they're not gonna [ __ ]
you for a few days
okay and i gotta be honest with you once
you rub one out
who gives a [ __ ] and you have to have
that clarity
when your nuts are full